this is a production of Cornell
University
that Thank You Alina and Mike for
inviting me I'd really appreciate the
opportunity
oh sorry can you hear me with this mic
okay great
okay yeah so as Elina said we I'm sort
of known as a root imaging and root
analysis person but it's really we're
interested in how the plant functions as
a whole and how shoots and roots are
integrated the way a plant actually
works and so this is actually data from
the pet imaging system my colleague
colleague on Shanthi at the Wash U
Medical School so you're actually
watching carbon being fixed in the
leaves and moving down into the roots
and in real time using pet and I'll tell
you a little bit more about how this
works later in the talk but again as I
think we all understand if we want to
understand the plant as an integrated
system it's usually the roots were where
we where we stop right these are the
bottlenecks so this is a classic image
of two grass roots interacting with one
another so there's just you know one
little shoot up here they're quite an
extensive root system so this is one
scale the architecture of the root
system that we can look at roots but
similarly there's a at each of these
many thousands of root tips there's
actually a microenvironment here the
rhizosphere so this is a the inside of a
barley root you can see the root hairs
here the soil particles this is where
the microbiome is happening so there's a
lot of dynamic activity across a lot of
scales so suffice to say roots are an
incredible challenge not just to see but
but in their complexity at many levels
and so from an applied standpoint we
often think about the concept of idiot
type breeding which was developed by cm
Donald in the 60s but an idiot type is
basically a model plant trade for a
particular environment or agronomic
practice and it was a big deal in the
Green Revolution and the idea is to
breathe for certain plant characters or
plant traits rather than simply
for yield or for reduced defects in
yield but as you might imagine Donald
didn't have a lot to say about what the
below ground video types are nonetheless
all the water all the nutrients and and
quite a bit of interactions with the
environment come through the roots and
through the soil and so this is a really
key area that we focus on in the lab so
this is how those images that you saw
this is from John Weaver's papers really
pioneered this sort of archaeological
approach to seeing and understanding
root systems in the soil this is
literally what they were doing to the
early 1900's and through the 50s and as
you can imagine the throughput was was
quite low
unfortunately 85 years later we're
literally this is still States state of
the art and this is not much hyperbole
here and so of the different ways that
we can actually look at roots in the
field each one has a very limited
perspective it's a very sparse idea of
the whole root system so there is a
phenotypic reality it's three
dimensional it's actually growing so
it's a four dimensional reality and each
of these root tips is growing along and
it's microenvironment it adds up to a
total architecture these are the methods
we can use today in the field excavating
soil cores many raisa Tron's which is a
clear - but the camera we can just see
the roots growing along the tube or root
crown excavations AKA shovel omics and
so just the idea here is that there's
course useful information we can get but
it's only a little sliver of the real
picture of phenotypic reality and it's
sort of a theme in my work so we're not
only interested in seeing the root
system but sort of making sense of the
complexity as well and tying different
forms of data together so ultimately my
group is interested in understanding the
genetic basis of root growth and route
environment interaction
and we very much take take a kitchen
sink approach and there's two general
axes here you know one is just
experiments we can control the
information content and on the other end
what's actually relative is a field soil
is actually relative to to agriculture
and so there's a number of different
methods and I'll touch on most of these
today but we take these these the
kitchen sink and we throw it at what I
like to call high resolution germ plasm
and the resolution is the resolution to
identify genes that are controlling
these traits and so I'll tell you a
little bit about the Illinois long term
selection experiment in maize and how
we're using these tools to identify
genes in a little bit first I'll start
with an imaging system for looking at
roots that was actually developed here
in Leon coaching's group at Cornell this
is optical projection tomography and
there's there's many of Leon's
former lab here at least Randy Clark was
the one and John shaft who really
pioneered this it's nothing more than
growing a plant in a big glass jar with
fertilizer and gel and spinning it
around on a turntable so here we have a
camera and an illuminator and we're
basically capturing silhouette images as
a rotating so we capture
three-dimensional information about the
roots and from that we can actually make
a three-dimensional model once we have
this model in hand we have to figure out
what to measure about it so we literally
have now phenotypic reality but how do
we capture all the variation here well
typically we start with the things that
we could measure maybe by hand or with a
ruler previously and then we get into
fancy stuff like shape analysis like
topological features or how the roots
curve over time things like this so
there's a lot of information we can get
but I'd like you to keep in mind that
these are really they're discrete traits
and they're ad hoc so they're basically
our human idea of what is important for
the root system and and to some extent
this may be limiting our ability to
understand roots and identify genes and
I'll give you a little bit of example so
I'm skipping ahead but we use this
method to map
the root architecture of a rice mapping
population so it's an upland and a
lowland the rice Phalaenopsis ain't a
recombinant inbred line so mike
explained qtls and rills earlier today
so basically what I'm showing you here
is just a few different chromosomes
where we found qtls and hopefully you
can kind of see the shaded areas the
color map this is where we found lots of
qtls of these univariate QTL so again
you know we may have found one for
bushing us or one for root system volume
or maybe even together in the same QTL
here okay but we we then we're wondering
well what's at which QTL should we
actually pursue which of these traits
actually matters most and this is where
we're working with homage olds I started
to get a perspective a multivariate
perspective about phenotype so what Tom
did is he took this whole list of traits
everything we could measure in Jill
Anderson and Ray in his lab and just
used a manova and basically used a
multivariate manova as the trait so a
similar thing would be to use a
principal component and map on a
principal component and the point of
this slide is just to show you we found
five multivariate qtls the ones in red
here and this is the effect size so
they're pretty large and red here these
are ones that we found with the
univariate traits previously so we
already had evidence that there was some
genes controlling the trait of interest
but in green here there was no evidence
of univariate QTL meaning we would not
have found this using these discrete and
ad-hoc traits and I think this is a very
important concept in in phenotyping in
general and I think all the speakers
this morning have really hit on the fact
that there's lots of information and
that together they tell the picture and
maybe not alone so a really beautiful
thing about this gel albeit an
artificial system of course is it's
non-destructive and so we can actually
look at the fourth dimension in time so
we think about plant environment
interactions or dynamics or processes
all of these all these words involve
time they imply time and so to not look
at them over time is severely limiting
so here we're looking at two
breadlines and we can see that there's
there's very different route
architectures but what you would like to
know is how the growth of each of these
individual routes how it goes from one
route to many hundreds of routes over
the course of seven days and how that
processes so how are they different as a
function of time and their growth
processes rather than just a static time
point so this is an automated imaging
system we have in the lab it's just
every four hours or whatever we decide
to program it at it runs day and night
and so we get these really nice
time-resolved datasets we've also
developed a software it's dynamic routes
published a couple years ago takes these
3d models and it allows us to actually
measure the growth of each individual
route in the context of the whole route
system over time so we can track
individual routes we can look at very
highly resolve level temporally and
spatially so this is work of needs yang
a postdoc in the lab so again just these
two different maize genotypes here we're
looking at a route length and so if you
just focus here it's shown as a density
plot so it was a function of the total
so basically in blue here these are
relatively shorter routes compared to
the relatively longer routes and that's
the same here for Missouri 17 and so
this is just to show you that the
beginning v73 has relatively longer
routes and that continues for some
period of time but at some point there's
really a flush of lateral roots and then
the the architecture continues with many
smaller routes rather than many longer
routes where azmuth missouri 17 over
time invest more in the routes that it
actually has and grow the grozny lateral
roots out rather than making more new
ones if then that makes sense so this
has really could be thought of as a
foraging strategy it's definitely a
growth characteristic that has
implications for how the plant is able
to forage for nutrients and and
resources in the soil you can also see
that you know clearly depending on where
you looked at your trade of interest you
would get different answers so if you
looked here it tells you one thing here
they're very similar and here you get a
different answer so similarly this is
just a number of lateral roots so that
you know basically what I showed you
before but you can see they're very
similar numbers and
some point at which b73 ramps up and
moves across so how do we actually
capture all this information in a more
comprehensive way so really in a
function rather than discrete values and
so we've we've we've started modeling
these these growth curves and so taking
this these patterns and the data and
converting them into a few variables
that we can then use to probe the
behavior and uses traits for the
genetics so this is again very basic
function most most biological things
start growing and they grow kind of like
an S and that is modeled well by a
logistic function and so you don't need
to read all this I'm just obligatory
showing you the equation here but the
point is that there's just a few
variables that we can use to capture the
data so it's probably better looked at
here again this is total route length
b73 Missouri 17 so at the final time
point this is after about a week of
growth these 73 has a more total route
length but it's pretty similar okay and
this this value is captured by one of
the one of the parameters the carrying
capacity alpha one and so we can see
that oops we can see that here where the
alpha one it's a little bit bigger for B
73 but not statistically different then
there's another tray the inflection
point which is where the growth rate
actually you can see it here better so
the growth rate is speeding up for B 73
and then it starts to slow down so the
inflection point would be right in the
middle and it would be somewhere on this
curve the 317 ramps up a little slower
but then it ramps down a little slower
as well and that's captured by this
value the slope of the line is captured
by these other two values and so
essentially we are were distilling these
growth patterns into variables that we
can then use to to differentiate the
genotypes or eventually to map James
okay so switching things up a little
this is what we can do with very high
resolution data where we can see and
know the whole route system course out
in the field which is where we really
want to know how
we grow and behave it's a lot different
so again this is a field of corn that's
a foot with a shovel that's a tank where
we soak the roots this is our mobile
field lab so it's got air conditioning
it's humane we drive it around from
field to field pile out of the back and
just dig lots and lots of roots and but
what you're looking at here instead of
measuring this by hand this is actually
a light and there's a camera inside of
it maybe you can see it here it's a
little dark but we take formal portraits
of the roots and we actually use image
analysis methods to measure the roots
rather than to measure them by hand and
so for this we as a software called dirt
and dirt is now on I plan it's free so
no excuse for anyone not to look at the
roots anymore just wash them off take a
formal portrait and there's a lot of
information we can capture then from
these two-dimensional images and so I'm
going to skip over this quickly actually
but there's a plan genome project where
we're doing a lot of this work and this
is at the core of it we're studying the
illinois high and low protein lines so
these are these lines have been bred
since 1898 for either high or low seed
protein content all this protein is
storing nitrogen so these are really
good at taking of nitrogen and these art
so to the extent that root architecture
should be conditioned by our nitrogen
uptake should be conditioned by root
architecture we should see that the
difference and so in the roots and so
for high and low protein you look
different to you there's something
different about them but what is it well
dirt kind of gives us a lot of
information about what it what it could
be and so if you cross these two things
together this is just phenotypic
variation and the real line so variation
is good if you're trying to map traits
and we've now used this too in a G Watts
analysis to identify candidate or snips
that are near candidate genes that we
think may be controlling root
architecture that has some bearing on
nitrogen uptake so this is the work of a
postdoc in the lab Jiang bean Lu here's
an example on chromosome 10 where we've
now we've drilled down to a candidate
gene that we think is controlling brood
architecture
and we have a number of these genes so
the traits really don't matter this one
is for root system with but again the
trade these traits are just capturing
some variation in the root phenotype I
they're not really meant to be taken
literally as my perspective so I'm
showing you here the sorghum ortholog
identity because we actually found
mutation at existing library and sorghum
so we think it's doing a very similar
thing in sorghum as our candidate gene
there's the wild type that we can see
clear root phenotypes here so we think
we're getting close to identifying genes
and this is important because we know
almost nothing about quantitative
genetics that control root architecture
so another part of this project and the
NSF partially funded and the other half
of the money came from valent
Biosciences who are working with on
rhizosphere interactions mycorrhizal
fungi and arise obeah and nodulation
this is an industrial scale x-ray
imaging system the x-5000 so you'll find
this in factory floors and automobile
and and aerospace industry and so it's
meant for big heavy things that are
dirty and that's kind of what plants and
pots are as well so very talented
research scientist keeps dunkin running
this this is what it looks like on the
inside so I've got a little schematic of
how it works but that's the source of
the detector that's the sample and this
thinkin's dinner spin around kind of
like the optical system you can also see
a lot of mechanics so we can do very
large samples so again quickly how it
works there's a source and a detector
and this sits on a very less something
with light density and as we shoot
x-rays through we get a contrast image
so the denser the material the more
tubes orbs the x-ray and that that
generates our difference in contrast the
cassava a pot with cassava root system
doesn't look like much but there's more
magic that happened so we basically
collect lots of these as we spin around
and then we can develop a
three-dimensional reconstruction and
I'll show you a whole litany of these in
a little while but as other features of
the system after we've spun around we
can actually because of the mechanics in
here we can actually move the source and
detector up and scan
across the whole plant and obviously
this comes at a cost of data and time
that we can do it about four feet and we
can also do what's called a mosaics
which is a tiling scan we can scan
across and so we can do very wide thing
so we have about a two by two by four
foot imaging volume and the voxel
resolution on that would be about 150 to
200 microns a nice thing about the
system is we can also zoom in so this is
a corn example of a corn kernel if we
zoom in and there's a software called
sub pix which gives us a little bit more
resolution we can get to about the five
to ten micron voxel size so it's a very
versatile instrument and just as a
real-life example of this this is a corn
cob we can scan and that's a kernel that
came off of it and so we can measure
lots of stuff within this corn cob and I
don't know if you can see this but also
there's a little maize embryo I think
we're close to being able to count the
number of leaves things like that
endosperm it's a lot of information this
that we then have to extract using
computation getting back to the roots
which is really the the why we've got
the system in the first place
to look you know at the hidden half of
plants so this is a corn plant grown in
a sort of a expanded clay what you're
looking at is just a slice turned like
this and as the movie goes you can see
the stem and you can see the crown roots
here nice and round as the movie goes
maybe you can track these but after a
little while once it start to get small
you're probably having a hard time
tracking those so this is really the
magic because what we have to do is
extract these roots back out of the
reconstruction so this is where
rotational tation is just a general term
for telling a teaching computer what's
foreground and what's background which
objects of interest and what's not so
that you can then measure your objects
so again me is working here on automated
or semi-automated methods for tracking
their roots and if you look carefully
there's roots that are missed there's
some things in here that are not so in
the end we get a reconstruction in it
it's pretty good I mean there's a lot of
missing roots and there's some stuff
that's not roots but we're getting there
this is an active area of research in my
group and just
in general in the field of imaging
sometimes segmentation is easy often
it's quite hard as mike showed some
examples of there's there's certainly a
lot of applications for machine learning
and nai em is pattern recognition so
here's an example again the
collaboration with bailant it didn't do
such a great job this is a soybean and
you should be looking at you know these
things we're looking for nodules those
are definitely not nodules or that the
world's biggest nodule you can actually
see them if you look carefully here but
the point is we're kind of getting there
but we're not quite there yet but you
know again as Mike mentioned if you have
very talented students in the lab or
studious and focus and methodical you
can clean these up with manual
segmentation so now this looks much more
like a soybean root and again we can
measure the litany of univariate rates
and we can also now identify the nodules
count the nodules how big are the
nodules how are these changing over time
we can now capture that in that
information okay so that's that's the
work we're doing there there's again I'm
just going to kind of go through stuff
since it was this was a tech forward
kind of meeting just to give you some
examples what we can see so not just
roots as the cassava root system these
are the storage roots and the fine roots
but not just the external morphology
also the internal morphology so this
actually is a little slice of the stem
it's just to show you that there's a lot
of information here for example these
are roots that are about to emerge
through the stem there's a vascular
tissue things like this we think we can
possibly use this in disease progression
for example to study
cassava brown streak virus as it starts
to develop inside of a tuber so that's
sort of an ongoing side project in the
group but the idea is not we can't it's
not only that we can see outside of the
plant but also inside so here's another
example this is a maize stalk these are
the crown roots and one emerges with
each leaf so we can actually see inside
the vascular connections between root
and across the leaves here in the maize
plant so again there's nothing
quantitative about this this now
requires some person or people to come
in and actually extract features from
this but the information is certain
there and so x-rays can can do a lot
here's something that's a little bit
easier to see this is a developing
castle and a maize plant so when we
think about flowering time and and and
environmental effects that affects
flowering we often think about it well
when the tassel pops out but actually
the primordia right when it's only even
smaller than this a few cells big is
more like the v4 v5 stage right it's
inside the stem and it's been growing
there for a long time so it may be that
the relevant time point we want to
understand the environment is way back
in time but you can see just from this I
can predict how many leaves that are
going to be on the plant before the
tassel emerges for example that's sort
of an obvious thing I could probably
count that by hand and so this is an
example of what it looks like a little
bit older so now we can see the
individual florets we can measure those
traits etc here's an example just for
mutant analysis right so this might be
an architecture that's kind of hard to
capture like how would you how would you
measure it by hand and Blake wasn't sure
about this but we we can capture it
inside of the stem as it's developing
and again use these computation to
measure how that's different from
Michael wild-type here's another example
in Soteria in fluorescence of just so
here's a mutant and here's the wild-type
so that gives you an idea of some of the
stuff we can do getting back to two
roots before I run out of time
completely one thing that we're doing is
trying to extract more information out
of the three-dimensional architecture so
I told you about dirt that's really 2d
so we're trying to extract information
from something we've flattened down into
2d we can scan these in about two or
three minutes depending on how big it is
and what resolutions we've been doing
this by the hundreds so now if you
wanted if I want to quantify the
differences between these two I can use
dirt but I can also use
three-dimensional data so here's what a
three dimensional it's very complex and
we're working with some topologists and
computer graphics people to clean these
up because there's actually a lot of
loops and noise but nonetheless we can
capture a lot of information from this
so I won't go through this experiment
but just to say that we basically took
the NAMM founders which sort of
encompass maize genetic diversity we
planted these out in our field in
Columbia Missouri
last year and we dug every week the
roots up so we have a time series sort
of a manual time series but a subset of
these at weeks four seven and tasseling
we also scan so it's about 250 plants
I'm not showing you 250 only three that
we've analyzed so far so at a sling is
the principal component analysis just to
show you the 2d dirt traits all the
things we can measure with that 2d
software principal component one does a
pretty good job of separating Kentucky
21 these dots from b73 Missouri 17 but
it can't really separate B 73 in
Missouri 17 when we take the x-ray data
into account all of a sudden we can now
cluster be 73 KY 21 in Missouri 17 much
better so I think that's because the
information contents higher it's
allowing us to separate these things
discriminatory power is really what
matters to us most and if we really want
to we can go back and look at the trait
loadings and we can see that solidity
for example is driving this and that and
we can actually quantify each of the
individual univariate traits as well so
we can get back to the biological
insight if we if we want to but really
what matters is discriminatory power so
each of these individual traits don't
mean that much to me personally it's
just the ability to separate and I think
that will increase our ability to
identify genes so in the final bit of
time there's a section I won't get to
but just going back to this pet this is
sort of a really interesting technology
again you're looking at carbon moving so
we feed this plan radioactive carbon 11
so short-lived radioisotope very
energetic and it's just fed it takes it
in confettis emphasis and starts moving
it down that's an imaging artifact so
you're looking at real time at the
carbon moving down the reason this is so
interesting is because now we're
actually looking at physiological
dynamics we're looking at what's
happening inside the plant that's
driving growth and we're able to overlay
that it's multimodal imaging with what's
actually
with the morphology of the plan and how
it's changing so you saw this that's
that's Ty's plant pet system and now we
can look at not only carbon allocation
and plant growth decisions over time as
a function of development so early on
there's no carbon going to the roots and
later we see that develop these are
three maize plants or subjects as
they're called at the med school we can
also look at this dynamically in real
time so just we have about two and a
half hour window with carbon 11 I should
mention
Margaret Frank who's about to start a
faculty position here has done a lot of
work with nitrogen there's a plenty of
other Radio isotopes you can use as
trace there's carbon just a really easy
one it's a gas plant takes it up and and
you can see it but so here's I don't
have much more time but here's a quick
example again if some biological insight
so this is the optical gel system you
this is a very young plant we're only
one leaf has emerged and so you can see
there's no carbon here in the roots you
see it in the chute here these are
different bed times where the shoots not
being shown the only carbon going to a
root at this stage is this crown root
here so it's a chute derived rudy you
can see a little spot there the next day
when the next leaf emerged all of a
sudden the the dam broke the plumbing
change the the seed ceases to be the
source of energy for the roots and now
the roots are growing being fed from
from the the leaves and the Photosynth
photosynthesis so this is an interesting
biological insight I think we can
capture with with this it would have
been hard to do otherwise so ultimately
we're using optical methods but now that
we have the x-ray x-ray CT x-ray pet PET
CT is actually where we're moving next
but the optical methods allow us to
overlay these two and actually ask for a
given amount of carbon at a root sip how
much of that root growth later so this
is something we're modeling and we can
see changes for example the jar we have
to use is kind of small so when the
roots hit the side of the jar we can
actually see a difference in the
relationship of growth to carbon
allocated so actual plant environment
interactions in real time so if we
wanted to example for example to query
the transcriptome or the metabolomic
series
if we wait till the roots have already
grown we've missed the dynamic event the
dynamic event that triggered the growth
was driving it happened before and
that's what we want to capture so I
won't have time to explain a
mathematical technique that we're using
similarly but I'll show you some cool
grey practices so we can use this
mathematical method to capture
comprehensive phenotypes this is from
the USDA collection so Jason Wanda who's
USDA and also here at Cornell it
represents grape genetic diversity and
just to show you with this mathematical
method we can actually discriminate
different grape breakers architectures
very well we're hoping to use this now
for route and shoot whole plants
architectures so you can read we have a
preprint here in viral archives work
we've done in tomato also a really nice
essay in American Journal botany if you
want to know more about mathematical
approaches to once we have the data to
actually capturing information in a
comprehensive rather than ad-hoc and
discrete way so I'll stop there is my
group at the Danforth center several
funders including the NSF USDA and
valent Biosciences and if there's time
happy to take questions thank
[Applause]
be detected your room Hockley both in
the jail and to shuttle only and what
other correlations yeah so I skipped
over that slide that the plant Genome
Project were explicitly doing that and
we're not finished yet but instead of
correlating a trait we can get from a
gel which is very high resolution and
what we can get is a field which is sort
of low resolution we're just comparing
at the genetic level so do we find snips
or QTL in common from gel from the field
and not only are we doing the shovel
omics or the superficial roots but
actually many Raisa Tron imaging that's
what Andrew leekie is doing so are there
any genetic signals in common which i
think is much more solid ground than
traits which vary depending on how you
measure them for example so thanks yeah
okay thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu